merci monsieur le ministre la parole est
à mme selwyn à l ouïe est pour le groupe
l'est républicain
merci monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur sur le ministre dès le 13
novembre au soir le président de la
république a annoncé le rétablissement
des contrôles aux frontières françaises
pour lutter contre la menace terroriste
or aujourd'hui les contrôles aux
frontières paraissent bien souvent
précaires nombreux sont les témoignages
d'anonymes sur les réseaux sociaux ou de
médias français et européen suite à des
déplacements dans les pays frontaliers
le 21 novembre deux véhicules d'une
équipe de tournage de la chaîne de
télévision nrj 12 franchissent la
frontière belge
sans rencontrer le moindre contrôle
alors même qu'il transportait des
caisses remplies de matériel le
lendemain une reporter du journal le
monde effectue un trajet aller retour
paris londres en eurostar
muni d'un couteau grand format sans être
inquiété
le journal le point note la rareté et le
caractère très aléatoire des contrôles
et dénombre trois contrôles sur 100
véhicules empruntant l'autoroute a2 vers
la belgique
il affirme que sur le millier de points
de passage potentiel entre la france et
la belgique
seule une soixantaine sont contrôlées
sur les réseaux sociaux de nombreux
internautes s'étonnent également de
l'absence de contrôle sur les routes et
dans les aéroports
en fait les contrôles réalisés sont à
l'heure actuelle peu nombreux de plus
ils sont faits sur les pour l'essentiel
sur les axes routiers les grands axes au
ticket et peuvent être aisément détourné
monsieur le ministre je ne néglige en
rien la difficulté du sujet mais vous
savez aussi que nos concitoyens ne
peuvent accepter qu'il y ait de décalage
entre les déclarations et l'action je
vous remercie donc d'indiquer à la
représentation nationale les mesures
précises et concrètes qui vont être
prises pour protéger efficacement nos
frontières contre la menace terroriste
merci monsieur débuté la parole est à
monsieur bernard cazeneuve vivre de
l'intérieur
j'ai le député gonnet lui avez vous
donné éléments extrêmement précis il y a
actuellement treize mille neuf cents
policiers qui sont déployés depuis le 13
novembre dont 9700 bolis y ait de la
police de l'air et des frontières et je
veux rendre un hommage très appuyé à ces
policiers qui permettent aujourd'hui
d'assurer des contrôles sur 131 points
de passage terrestres 115 routier 16
ferroviaire un point de passage maritime
22 points de passage aérien pour un
total de 105 4 points de passage
autorisés couverts par les forces de
police la gendarmerie nationale quant à
elle se trouve particulièrement mobilisé
la frontière franco belge puisqu'elle
couvre 32 points de passage
auxquels s'ajoutent six points
supplémentaires sur le reste du
territoire cela correspond très
exactement à 1400 gendarmes mobilisés
c'est à dire en tout quinze mille 300
policiers et gendarmes mobilisés depuis
le 13 novembre
je tiens à le souligner sur les
intervalles et les espaces frontaliers
de contrôle d'identité des ouvertures de
coffres sur réquisition judiciaire sont
mises en oeuvre et par ailleurs la
direction centrale de la police de l'air
et des frontières a déployé un
dispositif de contrôle mobile est
aléatoire sur les points de passage
autorisés secondaire à la date d'hier
ce dispositif a eu pour effet de refuser
l'admission sur le territoire de 832
personnes certaines pour des raisons
d'ordre public d'autres en majorité car
elle n'était pas en règle
afin de réaliser ces contrôles les
forces de l'ordre veillent à ce que les
personnes arrêtées ne soit pas inscrite
au fichier des personnes recherchées
lorsqu'elles le sont immédiatement des
contrôles supplémentaires sont mobilisés
mais comme vous le savez monsieur est y
compris lorsque le contrôle des
frontières existait avant schengen les
contrôles réguliers systématique ce
n'est pas l'étanchéification complète
d'une frontière dire le contraire serait
mentir aux français